e
of
yeah yeah
um I don't have an extra copy I
mean
yeah
okay sure so he just wanted to add um on
that Roman Roman numeral 4
A1 the the extra
line
um to say except when the officer
believes that that the animal's life is
in danger which makes pretty good sense
yeah and then in um number two under
cruelty to animals
livestock um a person charged in the
bill it says a person charged under this
section May petition the court to seek
an examination of the Animals by a
veterinarian licensed under RSA 30
332 hyphen B of his or her choice at the
expense of the person
charged and then we had a line that said
the person charged shall be made aware
of this petition in writing by the
arresting officer which which didn't
make any sense and I think that was a
drafting error so what the commissioner
suggested in his paper here to change
that line to read the person charged
shall be made aware of this right in
writing by the arresting officer sure
which makes a whole lot more sense so so
that's okay
um now we had in the bill right
underneath
here
um
charts got documents we working from now
the bill right the commission statement
and your I wanted to add a based on
testimony I wanted to add another
section number three that says if a
person is charged under this section and
is presented with any documents to sign
they must be given a full and honest
explanation of the contents of the
document and must completely understand
what it is they are giving their
permission for with their signature I
think that's very important yeah because
um clearly uh you know in some instances
people may be asked to sign something
they're under duress they don't know
what's going on they don't have a full
understanding of what it is they're
signing and then we have a situation
where which occurred which occurred yeah
which I think would be so that's that's
a a third part of this that I wanted to
add
in okay I agree then we uh have uh two
uh item two in this bill which is a new
sub paragraph having to do with
alteration of confiscated animals
prohibited
um
and what we had in the
[Music]
Bill said that prior to a conviction for
abuse or neglect under this section no
confiscated animal shall be altered
without the notorized authorization of
the owner from whom the animal was
confiscated nor such shall such animal
or animals be used in any manner to
solicit donations or to fundraise by any
individual organizations so what I would
do is strike that out okay and instead
put
in um item number
eight prior to a conviction for abuse or
neglect under this section no
confiscated animal shall be altered
without the notorized authorization of
confiscated and that's it but but I
would want to then add uh an item number
three instead of in the bill it says
confiscation of animal I I'm I'm kind of
inserting something and then moving
everything down so I'm going to be re
renumbering the rest of the items that
are in the Bill okay but to say that um
an to create a new subpar
paragraph and call it profiteering on
confiscated animals
prohibited to amend RSA 644 colon
8 uh Roman numeral 4A by inserting after
subparagraph 8 the following new
subparagraph number nine that says prior
to a conviction for abuse or neglect no
confiscated animal or
animals may be used in any manner to
solicit donations or to fundraise by any
individual or organization that has
protective custody of the animals okay
so do you have the wording of 6448 or is
that part of 6448 would be the one that
we're just doing there in the prior page
prior to a conviction for abuse okay
yeah so that's where it comes from yeah
Peter this is the um 644 the bill and I
put in in yellow the changes from the
commissioner and
heard
um so that way we're putting in we're
adding in with this
section this item number three in the
bill we're adding in a new sub paragraph
regarding
profiteering okay I don't know what the
legal definition for properer is but it
sounds if it is what it sounds like well
let's
look so 644
in the criminal
code colonate is cruelty to animals oh
well maybe we can change the word
profiteering
really Mr Bixby what say you to that um
mic how about I'm
uh I don't have my head around it yet
okay yeah profiteering just sounded I
don't know kind of like to me yeah yeah
yeah um um how about saying financial
better so because it is it seems to me
to be pretty unethical that you know
people who take protective custody of
the
animals would make profit off of I agree
the situation I
agree
okay so then we would have to renumber
uh item number three in the original
Bill to be item number four and in that
paragraph um I know that in the first
line it says except as
provided in sub paragraph
B any appropriate law enforcement
officer um um and it says or animal
control officer and what uh we were
suggested to by Farm Bureau was to add
in Municipal Animal control officer so
that um so that's a a word that they had
wanted to be added in there to make it
more clear okay uh the Animal control
officer who's doing this and then
we have some wording that says the
officer shall provide for Proper Care
and housing of any animal taken into
protective custody under this paragraph
and the commissioner had um requested
that we add in the line that says unless
charges have been filed the animal or
animals shall be returned to the owner
or caretaker upon
request so that way
you know if if they've been taken into
protective custody and within this this
time period if
no uh charges have been filed then uh
the the owner has right to take their
animals back presumably the charges get
filed early in this whole process yeah
okay yeah right so so one one challenge
is the distinction between
uh filing charges and uh having probable
cause uh so uh
and and I'm not quite sure how that
distinction so if uh so in a a potential
situation would be that uh there the the
owner was not present and animals were
found to be in a uh IM danger in
imminent danger and uh that that D that
that situation could likely have been
the result of um either neglect either
negligence or or Worse on the part of
the owner um if um so the but under
protective custody they wouldn't be
removed because of the potential crime
they'd be removed because in order to
preserve the health of the animals so uh
if there is a potential crime that
requires some further
investigation and uh so I think that uh
perhaps Al Another as another either far
charges filed or a warrant that
specifies probable specifying probable
probable
cause
okay I'm not quite sure how to do that
in terms of legal language it's the
that's not that's not my strong point
I'm better with h question yeah it's a
James far question so you're saying that
unless charges have been filed and then
you would want to insert something that
says or a warrant a a warrant
establishing probable cause or a
warrant
I mean the timing of all that confuses
me because in the case in the Lee case
um things sounded like got
accelerated um and I'm trying to imagine
how you get a warrant in
time so
um there are so basically there are two
there are two paths that that these that
this can go down one is that situation
is observed and observed by whom does it
matter it doesn't matter a situation is
observed the police are alerted
and they do an initial investigation
which would not which could not
initially involve going on the property
it it would have to be you know looking
at it from some distance uh because they
don't have a warrant to be on the
property and when they when they observe
from some distance if and and gather
other evidence that can be gathered
without being on the property they if
the if it seems like there is a
sufficient likelihood that there is a
you that a crime is being committed they
could go to the court and request a
warrant and they would have to uh list
probable cause on that warrant at which
point they could they could you know
they could um bring that warrant to the
property and that would give them legal
permission to be there um and uh at
which point they could then legally
seize animals as evidence in order to uh
determine if there was a an actual crime
was being committed uh that's one situ
that's one situation and under current
law there needs to be a status hearing
within 15 days uh in in order to or uh
and then in order to um determine the
disposition of the animals and um and
and and other aspects of the case which
I you know I it's been six years since I
worked on this so I don't remember the
details but uh so that's one SI that's
one situation the other situation is
they arrive at a at the location where
they've been alerted to animals that are
not being properly cared for the owner
is not present and uh they are and it's
the animals are in imminent danger and
they remove the animals for the animals
health so and they don't need a warrant
for that they don't need they don't need
a warrant for that uh so quite a
determination to make from John Q
public right so but but there is so um
on the other hand you if and one of the
the an example that the commissioner
brought up was that the
owner uh had been you know was um you
know in a in an accident and uh
incapacitated unable to say please
someone go care for my animals and the
animals are there they and they're
suffering from lack of care there is no
crime whatsoever being committed but the
animals need to be cared for right uh
and because of property rights issu use
the animals can't be cared for by an
someone that the author the owner does
not author authorize on the property so
they need to be and is incapable of
authorizing right yeah so so that's a
situation where it's the protective
custody would be purely for the sake of
the animals and there's no there's no
indication that any crime at all has
happened right uh so that's one purpose
of this in your earlier scenario I I'm
trying to Envision that somebody who's
not on the property can make that kind
of assessment law enforcement or anybody
else um I doesn't seem very likely to me
well um this is a little bit outside of
my my wheelhouse yeah but but but but
but it but but there is this you know in
order to in order to do the seizure
under
um which one is it the animal cruelty
um
the um in order to do it under that
statute I I I need to pull up my copy of
the statute to get the references right
but in order to do it under as a
criminal initial criminal action the um
you need to have there needs to be a
warrant in prob probable cause and I
don't know the deal details of how
that's established I think I think we
who
thank you one of the things that came up
in our hearing that you weren't able to
attend is that a veterinarian who knows
the animals and has perhaps treated the
animals might be in a better position to
animals I don't I don't see a
professional having a conflict they make
a
determination you know on the basis of
their
um office
yeah yeah
I also have aine
youed sure
sure copies this is something that I
send to all of you chair to send it to
you but it just gives you that didn't
happen overnight it wasn't day right no
that so with this
confiscation so with this confiscation
of
animals um this is does not say anything
about a um you going to speak up any if
you're going to be heard this doesn't
say anything that they can't it sounds
like they could be removed by um an
animal control a force enforcement
officer and nothing about a veterinarian
being present well that's probably in a
it where's the veterinarian mentioned uh
okay
so license just saying B Part B
investigating
officer shall be accompanied by a
veterinarian but that's not the removal
about be patient with us we have
multiple documents and um revisions I'm
just saying that this doesn't mention
that but if it is something that
remember these are only additions right
oh yeah these are additions so we have
yeah I guess I'm looking forward to
putting all the Amendments together you
know and we'll be able to follow it a
little more easily challenging to try
and go back and forth
um what you have you had mentioned Peter
in in this uh item number four
confiscation of
animal um in the middle of the paragraph
there we we added the the line from the
commissioner who he said unless charges
have been filed animal shall be returned
to the owner or caretaker upon request
and after that unless charges have been
filed or a you wanted to add in or a
warrant establishing probable cause has
been s sought or issued issued
okay
okay so this gives the um the owner the
opportunity to get their animals back if
there are no charges filed or if there's
no warrant or anything yes right okay so
so so that's the the situation where say
the owner was incapacitated and uh wakes
up in the hospital and says oh my gosh
my animals and contacts you know someone
who can who can act on it um that you
and and and take care of them that would
be um that would or or some other some
other situation where where there was
there's clearly no fault in there's no
crime involved it was simply a matter of
uh there was some intervening
circumstance in that case doesn't have
to be incapacitation right it doesn't
need to be incap incapacitation it can
be you know some some intervening
circumstance that made it impossible for
them to get back to their animal well
should we then say shall be returned to
the owner or their design yes okay
because um the owner may not in fact be
able to personally care for them but um
can provide a design okay all right so
then um additional if we move
oh yeah when they're the
um
there's what you said line
20 yeah of the so when when you cut that
in cut it in it knocked out the
right let
me nice to know that our bills are being
carefully read so we have to take that
and then the owner or caretaker it
should be put in
here as an former English teacher I can
tell you that the the three theirs
long no well punctuation was a lost
page okay got that that fixed thank
you
um okay so then after that line it says
if if after seven days the animal has
not been returned or claimed the officer
shall petition the municipal or District
Court seeking either permanent custody
or one week extension of custody or
shall file charges under this section if
a week's extension is granted by the
court and after a period of 14 days the
animal remains unclaimed the title and
custody of the animal shall rest with
the officer on behalf of the officers
Department we're striking out the word
or Society Department the department um
striking out the words or Society May
dispose of the animal in any lawful and
Humane manner as if it were the rightful
owner if after 14 days the officer or
the officer's Department determines a
change charges should be filed under
this section the officer shall petition
the court and um the commissioner says
here
on that
line is it on that line page
two page
two item
four e to seven yeah here that um an
owner or an animal taken into prot
protective custody shall have the right
to have the animal examined by a
veterinarian licensed under RSA 332b of
his or her choice at the expense of the
owner so that was in the uh italics and
Bold and the commissioner's comments
were um on page two the sentence
beginning on line five and ending on
line seven is not consistent with the
requirements of Roman numeral 4 A2 even
placing the same sentence here would be
redundant as Roman numeral 4 A2 would
apply to any charges which result from
the animal initially being taken into
protective custody so this sentence
should be removed because he's saying
it's it's a redundant thing yeah I had a
question mark next to that suggest
because I was having trouble following
because in Roman numeral 4 A2 it
specifically says a person charged under
this section May petition the court to
seek an examination of the Animals by a
Veterinary licensed under RSA 332 hyen B
of his or her choice at the expense of
the person charged so we've already said
that we don't need to say it again right
so the so um I don't know if it makes
sense I mean it from a lay person
standpoint it would make sense to have
something here saying that uh if the um
if it's determined that charges should
be filed then the um the provisions of
uh 4 a uh and 4 a and 4 a a uh are get
reverted to or something like that so
but I don't know if that I don't know if
that makes sense
legally yeah that would be a question
for OLS will we have time to send this
TOS oh yeah I'm GNA be going to talk to
them because I in terms of
uh if you don't put that in there it
might just seem like an absence yeah and
that and that someone might not
necessarily realize oh this is you know
this now reverts to uh to 4 a section uh
even though you know a lawyer would
recognize that probably maybe no but I
don't think that I don't think that a
police officer would necessarily notice
that
okay I'm G to put in my note here
yeah okay and then the next comment from
the commissioner which I didn't quite
um we had this next Item B that says for
purposes of that's on item line eight on
page two for purposes of sub paragraph a
the investigating officer for livestock
is a fine in RSA 427 colon 38 Roman
numeral 3 shall be accompanied by a
veterinarian licensed under RSA 332 henb
or the state veterinarian or their
design Who Shall Set the probable cause
criteria for taking the animal or
animals and uh the commissioner
said this does not have the language to
allow for extenuating
circumstances if this item Remains the
language should be consistent with the
suggestion made in Roman numeral 4
A1 which
says any person charged with animal
cruelty under paragraphs 3 or 3A may
have his or her animals confiscated by
the arresting
officer um however as this section only
allows for protective custody when quote
there is a clear and imminent danger to
the animal's health and life this new
requirement would be inconsistent with
the purpose of protective custody so it
should be removed so he is
saying that this language in Item
B should be removed altoe because it
doesn't really have anything to do with
protective custody which is what this
comes under that comes under right that
that makes sense to me because it that
that that would once again blur the
distinction between seizure for a
criminal under a criminal case versus
seizure or versus protective custom
custody which is not in fact a seizure
it is uh removing the animals for their
own
protection uh to be returned when the
protection is no longer needed so so
this should be stricken Al together
yeah
okay so then the rest is pretty you know
lines 12 through 26 on page two is
pretty straightforward we don't do um
live running or
harness uh harness horse racing or live
dog racing anymore so that whole section
is fine to be
eliminated
um so then we we had
um c section
c where we at we added in the bill on
lines 27 to
29 that we had originally said in cases
where one or more lactating animals are
confiscated proof shall be provided by
the confiscating party to the attending
veterinarian and the owner or caretaker
that proper care and faciliity shall be
provided for adults and
Offspring um
and so I added in
pink additionally in cases of
confiscation no lactating animal shall
be separated from its nonwe Offspring
and vice versa so that way we don't have
babies taken away from mothers or
mothers taken away from
babies not sure that the vice versa is
necessary because okay that you you have
two two ele two things there and if you
separate them then you separate them y
yeah okay so we don't need and vice
versa but I like the addition of the
sentence yeah okay and that's only you
know we don't want to also get confused
with dairy farming and how they do their
stuff over there this is only in cases
of confiscation is
that I think that the
nonwe covers that because when you're
talking about Dairy farming the
once the um once the calf is separated
from its uh from its mother you they are
not you know they've already it's been
separated as part of the the dairy
process it's not so that would be
essential that would be weaned and so
you know if the cat calf is being
bottled fed they'll that's being you
know or that's still weaned from its
mother that was your concern and so does
that address that well I guess I would
but doesn't doesn't the term wean
include all of
that I thought so yeah I thought I mean
if someone is if a if if a if a baby is
weaned then it's no longer nursing right
so yeah I mean I think that's and
whether or not the the mother is still
producing milk if the baby's weaned it's
y you have there addition so okay the
the
whole part here number item C in cases
where one or more lactating animals are
confiscated proof shall be provided by
the confiscating party to the attending
veterinarian and the owner or caretaker
that proper care and Facilities shall be
provided for adults and Offspring
additionally I'm adding this in
additionally in cases of confiscation no
lactating animal shall be separated from
its non weaned
Offspring yeah I think that takes care
of it
um then um we have this
language that Peter shared with
me we going down to e uh we're going to
talk about D oh okay because we have
here on
D no person natural or otherwise who has
initiated an animal welfare complaint
may take part in or be present during
any investigation into such complaint no
person natural or otherwise who may be
called up on to take possession of any
animal seized as a result of a complaint
under this section may take part in or
be present during such
investigation um the additional language
would to would be to say to protect the
Integrity of complaint
investigations and appropriate law
enforcement officer shall require any
person natural or otherwise called upon
to take possession of any animal seized
or to assist during any complaint
investigation to sign a binding
non-disclosure agreement intended to
protect any shared or confidential
information against unauthorized use
pending final adjudication or dismissal
of such complaint provided that
information may be disclosed only to
officials with the need to know who are
subject to confidentially
confidentiality obligations so that was
the additional language well I don't
think that Cas no no not not that I oh
that was um from uh Rob Johnson sent me
that what does natural or otherwise mean
in this
context I'm a natural person of the
Humane Society is a person under legal
definitions but it's not natural oh okay
and so basically and or
under under legal definition a person is
any entity that is capable of taking in
legal sense okay and the other either an
individual human or it can be a
organization yeah
right Madam chair what was the sign
binding agreement part could you read
me yes I I I had added in a section in
the beginning um as item number three in
uh section for for I thought this was
part of D that you were adding Rob
Johnson's no comments no okay we've I
added that in earlier to say that if a
person is charged under this section
that's on page
one if a person is charged under this
section and is presented with any
documents to sign they must be given a
full and honest explanation of the
contents of the document and must
completely understand what it is they're
giving their permission for with their
signature understood but the section
that you just read read from your
computer said something about a signed
binding agreement oh okay so the what I
um it was a long paragraph I got a
little loss so what uh what was said
here was the addition of the language to
protect the Integrity of complaint
investigations an appropriate law
enforcement officer shall require any
person natural or otherwise called upon
to take possession of any animal seized
or to assist during any complaint
investigation to sign a binding
non-disclosure agreement intended to
protect any shared or confidential
information against unauthorized use
pending final adjudication or dismissal
of such complaint provided that
information may be disclosed only to
officials with a need to know who are
subject to
confidential confidentiality obligations
too I have you might have addressed this
later but I have one concern about uh
this um the section three about if a
person is charged under this section and
presented with documents I'm concerned
that are we in the bill now this in the
beginning this this is in Judy's kind of
came in a little later on Section so I
just want to know if this has been
addressed but um that language needs to
have some sort of an equivalent under
the um temporary custody section also
because uh if someone's animals are
removed under test temporary custody and
they are presented with with documents
to uh that where would they would give
up uh ownership of the of the animal
they need to know exactly what they're
signing to because that's what happened
in the Lee case I sure there were I
Donal Lee didn't know what she was
signing no and uh she didn't realize she
was giving up ownership of her animals
she was not charged right so it needs to
be clear that um that uh you can't
Surrender Your animal no one can be put
in a position of surrendering their
animals either under a charge or under
temporary custody okay okay without
fully knowing what they're doing will
the same language obtain under the other
section I haven't figured out where it
should go I just I just know it needs to
be there fair enough okay so this this
has to be duplicated in another section
yeah yes yes
because because one is one is not one is
not necessarily one has to have the
protection even if one isn't charged yes
y
are
AG
in people are experienc
not to be of it it is unfortunate that I
have
a
Inge
year um we received 681 complaints
involving
animal
of2 um I would not take sign if I was
medical bills you might think Lisa welc
question com work with Dr Harvey and
I've been onse investigations with him
and then we housed those animals I
didn't Cee those animals Dr hary those
vinar decision we are
only we cannot get a search without a
police off so we have to have the
information work with the police to have
this happen we are not if the police
don't see it and the judge
I think that we just have to be careful
of the uning consequences of where you
will
put because un was an option
commissioner un isn't to take sick
trial
but the other
[Music]
concern that this
bill is Rush is still considered because
the other
concern is a civil liberties concern
that was brought up by one of the
chairman of the commission an
attorney that not
only when you talk about profing or
fundraising restrictions or
can there's concern there
but I would just say
that
many areas here
where there are uned consequences for
the animals of an that are now protected
by these people and a network of animal
protection and Animal Welfare
organization
longstanding decades and Decades of
service
State and every community in state that
are
beinged that nothing but provide comfort
and Aid to animals in this state on a
nonprofit basis every day and
Dr Who was referred to works for the
Department of Agriculture uh State
Veterinary works with the state veter
he's
here unfortunately there are no
point I understand I understand I
understand your passion but I will tell
you when I got home yesterday I had a
call on my phone from a farmer in Dairy
who is being harassed by the
ASPCA and
ASPCA I don't care if you're not the
ASPCA it's another animal organization
and this seems to be a problem well one
person's harass me is another person's
animal protection Mr Arenberg with
respect you know that we care about
these animals as well we are trying to
do by do right by them we are we are on
the same side but we have our job as
legislators is to make sure that the law
says
what our constituents want in terms of
protection and while the former speaker
said it's unfortunate that she may have
a conflict we do not have a conflict so
you and I know each other a little bit
I'm I'm an animal rights person but I'm
also called by my constituents and by
the oath I took to write the law so that
it reflects the will of the people
comment I mean I'm just going to say
clearly we have a problem and I think
that maybe one of the problems
well we're not trying the case at all
what we're trying to do is is put in
some uh solutions to issues to some of
the problems that arose out of this
particular case and other cases that
we've heard too um like I said clearly
there's a problem and what we're trying
legislatively to do is to make sure that
those problems don't occur and that due
process is followed for for the owner I
mean just as much as there are
protections for animals which there are
in the law we also need to protect the
owners of those animals from um
with respect we heard Miss Dennison's
testimony and I asked her one question
do you believe that the owner of the
animals was treated honorably and is
there anything you would do differently
and she said yes to the first no to the
second so we we heard her testimony you
can get it it's on tape okay well I
don't the purpose here is not to argue
um the purposes to try and and um come
for Madam chair yes I would like to
point out that this is a work session
and the members of the committee uh have
priority in the discussion and uh input
from anyone else including myself
actually is um is a matter of discretion
of the chair of the subcommittee yes
thank you for the
reminder okay um so where were we we
were on uh on
um Roman numeral Roman numeral 5
yeah we well actually we had item
e the confiscation of any animals
without the charging of the owner or
caretaker under paragraph 4 shall be
theft by unauthorized taking under RSA
637 Coen 3 that's to replace the
language that was in the original Bill
uh this is something that was uh
suggested by the
commissioner uh item e says the
confiscation of an animal without the
charging of the owner under paragraph 4
or the determination that the animal or
animal shall be taken into temporary
protective custody under this paragraph
shall be theft by unauthorized taking
under RSA 637 colon 3 so he wants to
replace that language with the
confiscation of any animals animal
animals without the charging of the
owner or caretaker under paragraph 4
shall be theft by unauthorized taking
under RSA 637 colon 3 so that's um a
simpler yes restatement restatement of
that yeah um then we have
um let's
see down
to so his last one was yep one one um
potential issue with that also is the
question of um the
uh the you know what happens if there is
a warrant for with probable cause that
uh where the animals are being um taken
as evidence the charges have not yet
been filed oh okay uh so I think that
needs to be I that needs to be allowed
also so okay so the confiscation of any
animals without the charging of the
owner or
caretaker
or um without a warrant without a
warrant
okay under paragraph
four shall be theft by unauthorized
um page three lines 20 to
end if the the language to provide an
exception in the ca the the
commissioner's comments to that
is if the language to provide an
exception in the case of confiscation or
protective custody is added in other
sections it would conflict with this
sentence that is um under in in yellow
okay if the sentence was amended to be
consistent it would then be redundant so
the sentence should be removed from the
section which is why I struck it through
okay um
um you got you you got that Peter yeah
got okay and then what I wanted to add
in was we had mentioned about adding in
the language for the cost of care
fund right so I'm putting in a new uh
item six in this bill a new
paragraph having to do with assessing
applications under the cost of care
fund um and I the use for livestock I
took the comments from the bill hearing
for that cost of care fund
okay um see it is have
thater so the comments for that
um had to do
with um the I know um Mr Johnson from
Farm Bureau said that
um before funds are released there
should be a some sort of check off and
assurance that the experts were
consulted part of due process of the
animal
owner um and so the so yeah commissioner
J Jasper was saying that there should be
some sort
of ability to
assess uh the application of the cost of
care
fund and that we would insert this
um
3A applications for reimbursement for
the care of livestock shall
demonstrate to the commissioner that the
livestock were seized properly according
to statute with assurance that
individuals with experience and
Professional Knowledge in the care of
livestock seized were consulted and that
proper due process was afforded to the
animal
owner does that make sense to add that
in I think so yes yes because they want
to make sure that you know before they
reimburse for the cost of care that um
it's been done appropr it's been done
appropriately the seizure yeah that
yeah you're not making
additional add-ons Peter to lengthen
it's some clarity yeah complete and
clear
yeah well we did say we wanted to add in
a piece because that was relevant to
this bill right no I'm not saying yeah I
think I'm not saying that that's an
inappropriate addition I'm just saying
that my general my
general take on it is that one should
use it key words as possible to indeed
make to get everything as clearly as
possible for sure
agreed okay so those those are the um
amendments to the
bill um incorporating the the um
commissioner's comments and then what we
heard in testimony too so so I'm just
sort of circling back to um the you know
who
you the the potential the the issue of
um no person natur otherwise who
initiated the comp um a complaint uh may
be part of the investigation and no
person uh who's called on to take
possession uh shall take part in the
investigation I think that might
actually I think that might be
problematic I think it's a little bit
too I think it it might be too broad and
um and sweep in too many you I I think
there there may in fact be unintended
consequences we do need our Humane
Societies to be able to take animals
that have been uh prop properly removed
from a situation and take care of them I
and I I think that one thing that that
helps deal with the issue behind that is
if we remove Humane Societies as a uh
essentially from being deputized which
and I I think I'm which I I think it
makes sense to remove the the
deputization that exists in current law
because I think it should be someone who
is re uh re responsible in the change of
command to the government uh in a clear
way as in a law enforcement officer in a
town or in the state um but uh but I
think that we don't want to say that um
we don't want to to get rid of potential
expertise
even if if there was if there has been
one case or two cases or three cases
where uh where procedures have not been
properly followed that is you know we
shouldn't throw out the baby with the
bath water okay so what do you do with
the wording in that se to re that I I'm
respon okay so maybe I'm thinking then
maybe we can change this to say no
person natural or otherwise who has
initiated an animal welfare complaint
may take part in or be present during
any investigation into such complaint
unless they have
um certain expertise or
credentials
to contribute to the I don't know how to
word that
yeah pardon me so here's how the work
session works you need to be recognized
by the chair if she chooses she will
to well do you have do you have ma'am do
that well we're working on that in
another bill
so yeah yeah yeah the only thing I was
cons um that commissioner Jasper said
they do not use they they have other
places that they put an livestock yeah
and not at the Humane Society was that
they have they have different places
where they can place
livestock I don't think that he was
excluding the Humane Societies as as as
a possible um place of housing I think
he was just saying that there there are
additional options places
okay well I I think maybe we need to in
incorporate some language that says
unless um
um unless they possess the
expertise
necessary right I I I think we're
getting into a fairly sticky territory
here that's um and I'm not sure that
this part is necess is absolutely
necessary
for uh to do immediately I think that we
had talked about doing a study committee
uh that would look at the that would
look at the entire entirety of this um
uh
6448 uh and I think that uh dealing with
that aspect of it might be put off
because I just
foresee just it it seems like there are
so many potential unint unintended
consequences to putting in that sort of
prohibition that it needs to have a more
thorough assessment than we can do in a
week
okay so do you want to strike that
language and then just add in um the
part that says to protect the Integrity
of complaint investigations an
appropriate law enforcement officer
shall require any person natural or
otherwise well that language that
um Rob Johnson sent me yeah okay
Sir
Orin yeah that's why we're not quite
ready that's why we're we're yeah that's
kind of why I'm thinking I want to
strike that section D and just add in
though to protect the Integrity of
complaint investigations and appr riate
law enforcement officer shall require
any person natural or otherwise called
upon to take possession of any animal
Seas to assist during any complaint
investigation to sign a binding
non-disclosure agreement intended to
protect any shared or confidential
information against unauthorized Ed
pending final adjudication or dismissal
of such complaint provided that
information may be disclosed only to
officials with a need to know who are
subject to
confidentiality obligations I think that
makes sense to put that there instead of
um prohibiting people from participating
in an
investigation so I'm gonna we'll do that
D
P
animal think about that be careful
animal back to the environment out so
something that we can into theill where
Chang be made the
envir to the animal and then no chares
have been done yet and petion
back in that same sitation took give
that thought
environment yeah we're trying to do so
much with this bill yeah
yeah um I'm actually thinking that that
might be something to put in at a later
time to um or a separate bill or a
separate bill at some other point yeah
yeah um I mean I think it's a fair point
for yeah it's a very fair point thank
you for
out
sure okay um I think I think that's all
for changes that we could do uh for now
and and um I'm going to go to OS and or
what I can do
is actually go to OLS and give them all
the changes and we can talk about it on
on Tuesday when we have our work session
the bill is not going to be exact out
until the 18th anyway because there's
done oh we can do that he wants me to
spend my summering this out well you
won't necessarily be the one of
stud well I think I will
be okay I I'm not going to compete for
it no I
to
uh review the entire statute the review
6448 and what else okay so
there's
um so
648 648 64
64 wait wait wait hold on a second right
I gotta see where you are here okay in
in in the statutes
there's we have there
are there's
by
are there's a set of Sub sub subsequent
form from
6448 a to g g with an AA there so that
red you one result of that might be oh
this just makes sense another part of it
might be oh this is something that is
you this doesn't exist anymore so we
want to make sure that so the
idea is to identify elements that need
to
be gaps in
logic things that might be
reorganized
[Music]
y to identify elements to clarify
reorganize
other
agult are the
statutes are statutes consistent with
current regulatory needs and practices
well hold on wait a minute you want to
send me that language oh sure I'll just
sure okay Kathy wants to study it before
she
get all right you're welcome thanks for
you that you aware of what
over
stat
okay thank you Dr har thank you for
coming
oh so yeah this is in their timeline
Donna Le decided to surrender the goats
that were seized due to financial
whatever um so we have time till 1130 I
sure are you are you all you're all set
Peter
suus and
check
okay
um we have a house resolution that we
are going to present by the way the way
you paired it down was perfect thank you
really good um we have a proposed house
resolution which I'll share with you uh
regarding the USDA Slaughter
Bill and Our intention is Tuesday during
Tuesday during the exec session we're
thank you for yes
thanks we were getting into a bad spot
weeds okay great I wish I'd thought of
it sooner yeah well I've been I've been
doing this for a while yes you have I'm
going to retire before I learn how to do
thank you thank and thank you for what
you
said
yeah we are on the
same yeah yeah yeah just not very good
no I I knew him 45 years ago at a tennis
camp and so he thinks we're buddies I
seen him 100 years but he's just not
very effective
angry and spouts off and doesn't do his
homework he's terrible
testify really I don't know why they
keep
him he's not very good that's a mystery
not no but anybody who I don't know that
anyway so we want to talk about the
musling bill which this one this is 250
250 you know with this the only I just
want to say something about this meat
bill yeah you know um I think that when
they process meat in these big um
um Factory you know like a big slaughter
houses they do it mostly by Machine
whereas you know the ones that are local
are doing it some machine but mostly
hand so I think that there's better um
you know
practices
anyway so with this
um with this musling
bill um obviously this needs need some
Amendment were you working on an
this I don't remember
um but I know that we we said that um we
wanted to change this to have some kind
of thing that
says that they could uh
regulate
locally only with a bite history or
where you know
um New Hampshire law has two places
where this could be added was my note to
said all right let's see I know I know
we've got legislation already having to
do with bites and there was something
that Stacy
over yeah she's sent a whole list of um
two bills in her statement that I looked
um it's a
model
um International Municipal Lawyers
Association model of dangerous dog
ordinance it's quite detailed but upon
review May flag issues not contemplated
in hb250 authorizing municipalities to
muzzle
dogs AKC has a white paper on breed
discrimination that includes model state
law for your consideration as to what
guidelines should be useful to New
Hampshire cities and towns dealing with
dangerous dog
issues
um but I think for the most part the
concern with
that yeah we want to give well first of
all we've got we've got laws on the
books for
um vicious dogs let me go look that up
section you know I struggled with the
you get to bite somebody once before you
have to do it but I guess there's no way
around that 466 colon 31 y dogs a menace
a nuisance or
vicious so okay so let me write this
down this is
all right under this section a dog is
considered to be a nuisance a menace or
vicious to persons or to property under
any or all but not limited to the
following conditions a if a dog is at
large which means it's off the premises
of the owner or keeper and is not under
the control of any person by means of
personal presence and attention as well
as reasonably control the conduct of
such dog unless accompanied by the owner
or custodian this subparagraph shall not
include a dog which is being used for
hunting supervised competition
exhibition or training for such
activities if accompanied by the owner
or custodian or a dog which is guarding
working or hurting livestock as defined
in RSA 21 colon
34A Roman numeral 2 A4 meaning that the
owner or custodian must be able to see
or hear the dog or have a reasonable
knowledge of where the dog is hunting or
hurting or where training is being
conducted or where trials are being held
provided that such dog does not have to
be within sight at all time okay so that
just gives you the definition of if a
dog is at
large okay because Mr Dam's point was
right ex dogs so he wants to make sure
that those dogs are not muzzled
right and Stacy want to make sure the
dogs aren't mule Stacy wants to make
sure that dogs aren't muzzled because of
their breed right uh which are both
reasonable concerns right uh so um but
there's nothing we've said here that
okay then it says if it's also a dog is
considered to be a nuisance a menace or
vicious if it barks for sustained
periods of more than a half hour or
during the night or so is to disturb the
peace and quiet of a neighborhood or
area not including a dog which is
guarding working hering livestock is
defined in RSA 21 colon 34 A2 A4 it's
also considered a nuisance am Menace or
vicious to persons if it digs scratches
or excretes or causes waste or Garbage
to be scattered on property other than
its owners so in your yard yep um
also um if a female dog in season or
heat is permitted to run at large or be
off premises the owner or keeper deep ER
during this period except when being
exercised on a leash by responsible
adult at all times such dogs shall be
confined within a building or enclosure
in such a manner that she will not come
in uh to contact except for intentional
breeding purposes with a male dog a
female dog in heat shall not be used for
hunting um a dog is considered a
nuisance Menace or vicious if it growls
snaps at runs after or chases any person
or persons not on the premises of the
owner or
keeper it's also a nuisance if it runs
after chases bicycles Motor Vehicles
motorcycles or other vehicles being
driven pulled or pushed on the Street
Highway or public way not supposed to be
loose to do also it's considered a
nuisance Menace or vicious if whether uh
alone or in a pack with other dogs it
bites attacks or preise on game animals
domestic animals foul or human human
beings so clearly the animals in
question that we're talking about are um
there are various descriptions here of
what constitutes a dog that's Menace a
nuisance or vicious quite complete I
would say quite complete I don't think
there's anything that needs to be
changed there um then it says in this
Statute in
2A if the skin of a person has been
punctured by a dog and the incident was
reported including the identity of the
dog and its owner to the animal officer
if any or to the town clerk such officer
or clerk shall within 24 hours notify
the injured person or in the case of a
minor the Minor's parent or Guardian
whether according to town records the
dog has been appropriately immunized
against rabies so there's that thing is
within with an instance of an attack or
dog bite that U the person who was
bitten has to be contacted to let them
know whether that happen in the leblan
case I don't know we didn't hear I
probably I would imagine I'd have to go
back and listen if and it says if any
any person who fails by appropriate
action including but not limited to
restraining an animal from running at
large or otherwise effectively abating a
nuisance found such the provisions of
this section or who fails to comply with
any other provisions of this section
after being so ordered shall have the
person's dog taken into custody by the
police of the city Constable of the town
or other person authorized by the town
and such disposition made of the dog as
the court May
order so I
wonder what's the problem here that
we're trying to solve that
isn't uh vested in that stat well what
they're trying trying to say is that the
um you're not able to um want that dog
muzzled when it when it's on a leash in
public
and there's nothing in there that says
that you can Muzzle you can demand that
that dog be muzzled if it's in a crowd
of people or if it's around other dogs
or like that it hasn't bitten right so
so the the
issue is has to do with local control
versus State Control okay and the
attorney the City attorney for
Keen thought that the fact that there
that musling exists as a practice in
state law indicated that that's
something that community that localities
didn't have the power to do themselves
and I
don't um I am
slightly dubious about that reading
however a trained lawyer I I also think
a trained lawyer probably is has more
experience in terms of reading the the
potential pitfalls of uh doing city
ordinances that might conflict with
state law than I do so I'm not gonna I'm
not GNA argue that right uh so um I
think what the solution here might be is
if we look at the
bill uh it's quite short it's pretty
short which is a nice thing yes um so
um the local governing body may take
such additional bylaw make such
additional bylaws and regulations
concerning the licensing muzzling and
restraining of dogs as it seems
reasonable that has been deemed to be
overly broad the musling so one thing we
could do
is um put in another sentence saying
that um the local governing body may
make additional
bylaws uh concerning dogs that are
deemed a nuisance or vicious under the
statute the Jud just went over what and
and and uh including and then uh in
including requiring musling requiring
there there's a whole list of things in
what um was quite comprehensive I
thought that that
um that Stacy sent us and uh we could
include you know a certain number of
those as you know possible things that
the uh that the community could make
laws about so um leash
muzzle um
confinement uh indoor confinement signs
liability insurance identifi
identification photographs microchips
spaying neutering I think that we I
probably don't I don't think spaying
neutering makes should belong on the
list let's let's first look at what what
are the the
penalties uh in in 466 colon 31 hyphen a
talks about the penalties about um if if
a a a dog is
um is a problem right but I think that
what's what the town was looking for
wasn't so much a way of punishing
because they did they did they did love
you fine that's not that's not
necessarily going to solve the problem
the what what would solve the problem in
this particular case is if the dog had
been muzzled right um and so there are
and but but I think though and I don't
mean to interrupt you but I think though
if the person is fine and then no no
action is taken after that then it's
when the municipality can then say okay
well you're you a fine didn't work you
need to muzzle your
dog or you could say another possibility
is that there are a set of interventions
that can that can happen before the F
before a fine is levied so I mean
frankly if I were you know if I were in
the situation where you know my dog was
deemed I I wouldn't be in the situation
but if I were in a situation where my
dog was deemed to be unsafe to travel
the you know travel on the street uh
without some further you know
safeguards I would much rather say have
someone say if you're G to have your dog
outside it's got to be muzzled then you
need to pay the city 200
bucks so I I so I I think that uh
allowing this so allowing the city to
have certain behavioral options that uh
and and this would this would all be in
city by why we we don't need to do it at
the state level but allowing in state
law for cities to to uh require certain
interventions is that what your language
that you just gave us yes so the so the
so the Lang and I haven't written down
the language or anything but spinning
off my top of the head the the you know
in the case of a dog deemed a nuisance
or vicious under what the statute
um uh the you know a city may have ordin
ordinances
requiring uh musling leashing okay
microchipping and the other thing I
don't know um how we you know could put
it in there but um if you have a younger
person or a slight buil person um trying
to control one of these vicious dogs
they they can't hold on to them
sometimes so having a muzzle on them
would really help if if something
happened I have been in a situation
where someone could not control their
dog and it dragged them across the
parking lot and if the dog had and she
was so small that she should never have
been trying to hang on to a dog dog like
that yeah so that's where I think
muzzling would really and before before
they attack I know that's the problem
yeah that's they have to they have to
bite somebody once first but well I
think there were other things that that
that um would qualify it as being
vicious or nuisance before it bit
someone like chasing bicycles I I in my
time of bicycling I have I have had some
scary experiences with being chased down
by a a pack of
dogs I once dog sat for a springer
spaniel who'd not been trained I could
not walk that dog and I'm not that small
or weak but he was so strong and he
didn't know how to follow a
lead yeah so so I would just suggest
that in terms of we say something like
we take out this musling thing whatever
or we can just just even replace the
whole bill um that what in 466 colon 39
City or bylaws we can add a uh take the
musling thing out but add a sentence at
the end of that that says if a dog is
deemed vicious or a nuisance as defined
by RSA 466 col 31 the local governing
body May adopt ordinances as it deems
reasonable um okay um so I would
slightly change that so I or is that too
broad no it it's just kind of reversed
so the S because that's that makes it
sound like the ordinance is in response
to a particular dog which is not what
we're trying to do it's it's so the the
city or the municipality May adopt
ordinances uh for the control or
restraint or restraint I like restraint
man management for the management of
right of dogs deemed vicious or nuisance
under RSA citation y so the governing
body
May
adopt
management
of dogs
deemed um
menacing vicious or
or
a we've got adjectives and verbs so what
is it the local governing body May adopt
ordinances as it deems reasonable for
management of dogs deemed vicious as
too
yeah but does it say musling is is that
included so that no this just this just
describes Menace n Menace nuisance and
it's going to refer back to to write
thein
um so musling would be considered would
be a management practice so this also
said this also means that if you've got
a dog that's barking over a half hour
over a half hour in the middle of the
night the the municipality can make
ordinances to deal with that right yeah
now are the people is jod new and the
people that are supporting the musling
thing going to be content with this is
this answer well this I think is a lot
broader than this
they wanted they basically wanted
something to
Da uh that would give ke the ability to
pass an ordinance that would deal with
situation right yeah I like putting it
back on the municipality to determine
the wording of what they need yeah what
they think is reasonable I like that
phrase
too well I wonder if 466 colon 39 the
city or town bylaws if we can write
rewrite that
whole paragraph because it says the
local governing body may make such
additional bylaws and regulations
concerning the licensing musling and
restraining of dogs as it deems
reasonable and may affix penalties not
exceeding $50 for a breach thereof such
bylaws and regulations shall relate only
to dogs owned and kept in such a city or
town and the annual fee required for a
license shall in no case be more than a
dollar in addition to the sum hereby
required
so I think if we're saying the local
governing body May adopt ordinances as
it deems reasonable for management of
dogs deemed vicious a menace a nuisance
or vicious as defined by RSA 466 colon
31 that kind of
replaces yes I think so the first
that
um well we don't want to say both the
local governing body may make such
additional bylaws and also say the
municipality May adopt ordinances I mean
isn't that redundant oh yeah that's yeah
make laws and regulations would be the
same as ordinances ordinances y so I oh
so oh but you're you're thinking that
restraining
reasonable okay but but there may be a
question
so you might there there are some there
are some reasonable ways there are some
situations where it would be reasonable
to require the Restraint of a dog when
the dog has not been deemed to be so you
don't want to take that away from so you
don't want you want you don't want to
say that that the city can't make
a a leash law right um because and you
know
and and that you know in you know that
there are certain areas that you would
be required to have your dog have a dog
on a leash whether or not it is you know
considered
problematic um so so you can leave the
restraint in so I think the restraining
needs to be there and then the the
management of vicious dogs is on top of
that
and does the penalty piece work for
people
um I have no idea how much you charge
for these
things well there's a different set of
penalties
for under the the vicious dog right
thing right yes it's it's a whole
paragraph of
them
um so my my thing
though just aside from this my thing
though is I just don't want to have a
situation where you have somebody in
town who has a dog the select board
doesn't like this guy and they're gonna
make some kind of ordinance targeting
this
guy or you know
make do something that's going to you
know get after him for dog they don't
like something else about his property
that's why I'm kind of like leaning
towards
words they can't just say that they want
to muzzle an animal they have to have a
cause for doing that there has to be and
I think in here where it says you know
what um if it's running after somebody
who's on a bicycle if it's uh uh if it
bites somebody there has to be some sort
of yeah so so well the the restraint so
the the existing language in terms of
restraint can be I I and that's been
there for a long time yeah and it's
broad enough to let them it's broad
enough that and my sense is that
basically has largely has to do with
leash laws yeah um and is that a cityby
city thing that's a city by City thing
oh I didn't even know that I think there
might I don't know there might be a I'm
not sure if there's a Statewide lee law
too I don't um doesn't matter for our
purposes today um but I I don't think we
should mess with the existing thing
about licensing and restraining I think
we just need to add language saying that
specifically for vicious dogs well why
don't we say mus in in this I got here
how about this the local governing body
may make such additional bylaws and
regulations concerning the licing
licensing
musling of vicious dogs as as described
in RSA
46631 and restraining of dogs as it
deems reasonable
okay that way we're we're putting the
reason for muzzling the dogs in the
nuisance slot okay sure um that that's I
think that that
is that's simple enough I this that will
deal with this particular situation and
um right I I guess that
what what Stacy had been sort of
indicating was that there are a number
of different mechanisms for managing
dogs that are are problematic and you
might not necessarily want to limit
yourself to saying that it should be
muzzled that in some cases you know
there might be other management
practices well you want to just say
instead of musling management of vicious
dogs as describ
as as um defined
in
RSA do you lose something by taking
um well I'm I just I I'm kind of up two
the the
raising when when it turn when just in
terms
of I think I think CH putting Management
in in that way creates an IG a language
ambiguity because
it's it might
it so there is nothing in
466 uh whatever it is 31 4
31 that talks
about uh specifically about musling but
there are implications in that chapter
about
management
and so I'm thinking
that that could be read by someone who
didn't know our intent as the management
has to be something that's in
46631 oh I hear what you're saying so I
think I think it's if we're going to go
with that more limited phrasing that
you're suggesting which I don't think I
think is is reasonable then we need to
musling and I didn't understand and the
bill is about musling the Bill's about
musling and I don't think so I I think
it's not crazy for us to just focus on
you know use use musling and I think we
have if someone comes back with another
bill at some point right that where they
want to you know revise the entire
question of
how um unruly dogs are dealt with then
we'll deal with it again that in the
future but I think this I think I'm I'm
now leaning towards making this just as
small as we need to make it okay yeah I
don't want to see that one um man that
uh had hunting dogs if they run off his
property to cross the road chasing a
rabbit or whatever they're doing I don't
want to have him call and force him to
musle well that's why we need this
definition linked to this right to this
RSA there there is a there is a the
does exclud does exclude
yeah so that um yeah
yeah that works for
me so we want to say musling
of the local governing body may make
such additional bylaws and regulations
concerning the
licensing musling of vicious dogs as
defined in RSA
46631 and restraining of dogs as it seem
as it deems reasonable yeah right yeah
yep
okay okay and you leave the penalties as
is y yeah yeah all right there were also
additional penalties in 46 631a so okay
that have to do specifically V with
vicious animals
so
okay so I can put that in as an
right no study committee Kathy on that
one
oh my gosh okay I'm gonna I'll put that
amendment and you at some point in the
future it might make sense to just
review this whole chapter but not not
this week yeah right okay so I'm gonna
and thank you for coming Peter and Judy
actually both of you yeah
Kathy and I would have been struggling
to do this on our
own oh I wouldn't have been able to do
it at
[Music]
nearly different gifts that's what they
say
oh
e